el 3 de junio de 2015 las argentinas
alzaron la voz e inundaron las calles
del país para rechazar la violencia
contra las mujeres tras el asesinato de
un adolescente de 14 años embarazada y
asesinada por su novio de 16
[Música]
hoy siete años después las feministas
celebran largos meses de lucha y logros
aunque remarcan que todavía queda un
largo camino por recorrer y todavía no
hay respuesta
inmediata a las situaciones de violencia
no tenemos respuesta y muchas mujeres
que terminaron en asesinadas tuvieron
situaciones con la policía con el
ministerio
de reclamo previo de denuncia y su
insignia sigue siendo la misma que en
2015 ni una menos en referencia a la
consecuencia más graves de las dinámicas
abusivas contra las mujeres el
feminicidio con unos objetivos que se
expandieron por todo el continente
americano y por el mundo entero y que
fue evolucionando de la lucha contra la
violencia hacia las mujeres a la
reivindicación de sus derechos como el
derecho al aborto un pedido histórico en
argentina ya legal en la nación hasta la
semana 14 y ahora - también es filial
para que no haya más abortos
clandestinos y es que a pesar de que las
cifras han mejorado en los últimos años
en 2021 una mujer fue asesinada cada día
y medio en argentina en lo que llevamos
de 2022 y así han registrado 104
feminicidios una forma de violencia que
no entiende de edades
era una selva ahora las argentinas se
exigen una reforma judicial con
perspectiva de género que evite que más
mujeres sean asesinadas